welcome back to the 1980s into my
birthday show
thank you everyone who's just surprising
that video that was so sweet um this is
a show where everything is literally a
surprise to me even these words i'm
reading right now
i wanted to also say a big thank you to
everyone who helped us give away that
amazing trip to london that was so cool
shout out to
jackson
she is amazing but
i gotta cut you off real quick
happy birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
um
i woke up
15 minutes ago i love you i forgot my
shoes so i'm wearing my house
you were like i ran that's me like
getting to i still feel like a teenager
sometimes i will show up in my pjs yeah
i like they i thought i had i thought we
weren't they were so you had more time i
had more time and they were like you
have 15 minutes you have to get here now
and i got in the car and they were like
where's your shoes and i was like i
don't have my shoes but i don't care um
i actually so i know it's your birthday
every year because it's also my birthday
i did not remember that we had the same
birthday i think we might have talked
about it well my today yours is your
birthday is today oh okay but you're a
tourist yeah we're amazing
yeah we're amazing happy birthday thank
you but it's exciting i didn't just come
with my wife
on your birthday to oh that's kind no no
it's cool it's cool is it yeah i brought
a little celebration i didn't just bring
my my slippers out
your slippers
okay so uh if you don't mind i would
like to hit it ladies [ __ ] ladies
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that
[Music]
[Applause]
happy birthday you guys that was so
sweet oh my gosh thank
you so much
look at this case though
thank you
look at this queso ladies
are we gonna do it
i've never done this with a how have i
never done this at a party i'll go
who what kind of though i'll go home up
i love thailand y'all wanna know you
have a piece of heaven right here oh my
god
and margaritas
all right come
on kelly
happy birthday to you
thank you there we go
oh my god so and you brought
the mariachi bonitas i love this um
thank you so much for coming oh thank
you
we were beautiful we wouldn't miss it
for a while just so you know snoop would
be so jealous right now he loves this
music we talk about it all the time um
thank you so much i like your slippers
take some queso on the way out
oh you can even wrap up the flour
tortilla in it i like it i like it okay
bye everybody go back to home base they
told me to tell you
i'm going back to home
i love this show
i don't know if i was supposed to bring
my margarita but i did
thank you so much for the gifts and
stopping by happy birthday
machine gun kelly's latest album
mainstream sellout hit number one on
billboard
get it wherever you get your music and
look for him out on tour this summer
that's exciting tours are back y'all
[Music]
you